So,
okay,
so about two months ago made these videos.
Um,
I did it because I was trying
to articulate my concerns.
Um,
you know,
sometimes when you're having a debate
or discussion with someone that you love
and you're having a little argument
about something like who's gonna do the
dishes or something like that.
Her,
especially if you haven't been getting
along very well with that person,
you know how the discussion starts with
something specific and then you start
trading all the things that it might
be about until you're arguing about,
you know,
the way that you behaved
on your third date,
you know,
10 years ago.
And the whole underlying unresolved chaos
of your relationship emerges through
the little portal that was
defined by the argument,
you know,
well,
that's what this is about.
And when you talk,
it doesn't mean you're right.
It doesn't mean you're correct,
right?
It means you're trying to articulate and
formulate your thoughts like the bone
headed more on net.
You are,
and you're going to stumble around
idiotically because what the hell do you
know?
You're full of biases and you're
ignorant and he can't speak very well and
you're over emotional and you know you've
got just problems that you can hardly
even imagine that are interfering with
your ability to state something clear.
And so what you do is you do your best
to say what you mean and then you listen
to other people tell you why
you're a blithering idiot.
And hopefully you can correct yourself
to some degree as a consequence of
listening to them.
And you see that's what
free speech is about.
It isn't just that people can organize
themselves and their societies by
thinking you can't do that
because there's only one of you.
What do you have to do is you have to
articulate your thoughts in a public forum
so that other people can attack you
and hopefully in a corrective manner.
And then you want to,
you know,
step back a little bit and think,
okay,
well,
you know,
I was a little arrogant there and I
was a little over emotional there and I
didn't get that quite right.
And maybe I'm outright
biased on that front.
And you,
you want to correct what you say because
then you correct how you are and then
you correct how you act in life
and then you correct your society.
And to the degree that we limit
free freedom of expression,
we put all of that at risk.
And that's partly why I don't believe
that freedom of speech is just another
value.
I think that's preposterous.
I think that if you claim that,
then you know nothing about Western
civilization and history is freedom of
speech is not just another principle.
It's the mechanism by which we keep our
psyches and our society's organized and
we have to be unbelievably careful about
in infringing upon that because we're
infringing upon the process by which
we keep chaos and order balanced.
The proper citizen is the person who
embodies truth in speech and attempts to
act it out.
And that also includes listening because
listening is part of communicative
intent.
And I think at the moment that we're in,
we're embroiled in a war on every single
one of those dimensions and several
others that I haven't had time to list.
And the evidence that we're in that sort
of war is precisely the fact that this
has attracted so much attention.
I mean,
I just sat my bloody office at home and
threw up a couple of amateurish videos,
more or less,
attempting to articulate my feelings
about a couple of policies and it's all
hell broke loose and why?
Well,
because that hell is right
underneath the surface.
So I'm going to read you something that
a graduate students sent me from the
University of Toronto the other day.
And I can also tell you that I've received
hundreds of letters like this today.
I had a tutorial at the University of
Toronto where I talked about Jordan
Peterson and issues of personal identity,
legally sanctioned identity categories,
et cetera.
I brought up a video of a tall white man
in his thirties who asked students out
of university how they'd
react if he told them.
He identified as a woman,
as black,
as short and is five years old.
Spoiler alert.
Students in the video resists some
of the later categories a bit better,
mostly accepting.
Still students were not
engaging in discussion.
I asked them why one said it was because
she was worried to share her opinion
for fear of being singled out
or saying something offensive.
I asked who else was not
speaking for that reason?
The whole class put their hands up.
No participation.
Why
they weren't uninterested.
They were afraid to speak their minds.
The PC police are in your heads.
I'll start with lawyer one who was the
counsel to several prime ministers.
He talked to me about the human rights
tribunals cause I went and saw him two
weeks after this all started.
Human rights tribunals is a
kangaroo court in my opinion,
and it should be abolished
as fast as possible.
It's one of the many institutions in
Canada that pose a threat to your,
to your freedom that is almost
unimaginable proportions.
Here's what this top lawyer told me.
If I'm taking it in front of the human
rights tribunal and will cost me $250,000
I will pay the legal costs for
my opponents and I will lose.
He said,
go back to your safe little
life and shut your mouth.
Okay.
Second lawyer told me my critique of the
Ontario Human Rights Commission is spot
on and absent the charter
of rights and freedoms,
which has these contradictions built
into it that you just heard described.
Much of what I was saying was illegal
and has been illegal since 2012 lawyer
three told me that if I
breached a tribunal order,
so imagine I was taken in front of the
human rights tribunal and I was fine and
then I refused to pay the fine,
which I've stated that I would do.
That equals contempt of court,
which inevitably means jail
until the contempt is purged.
The social justice tribunals and the SJWs
social justice warriors who staff them
have a robe nature.
They can search your
house without a warrant.
They can use secret hearings.
There are no rules of evidence
and the judges are unaccountable,
but those are legal opinions.
Let's,
let's look at a real world case.
Let's look at what happened
when I made my videos.
Let's look at how the responded
because I can tell you in the video,
I said,
look,
what I'm doing is probably
illegal and worse.
My employer is legally responsible
for it because that's built in,
that's built into the codes as well.
So by the way,
if you're an employer,
you're responsible for everything that
your employees say and everything that in
anybody interprets what
they said as being,
whether it's unintentional or intentional,
whether or not a complaint has been made.
So just think about that.
Anyways,
October 3rd the university said like
all members of the university community,
I have an obligation to comply with
the law including the provisions of the
Ontario Human Rights Code,
their policy with regards
to workplace harassment,
which the university implied that I
was engaging in engaging in a course of
vexatious comment or conduct where the
course of comment or conduct is known or
reasonably be known to be unwelcome.
The university reviewed my videos and
they decided that what I said was true.
They decided that the video I made was
probably illegal and that they were
responsible for it.
And so in an attempt to
distance themselves from
me under counsel from their
legal people,
and believe me,
the university has good legal people.
They sent me a warning,
and this is what happens if you want
to discipline a recalcitrant employee.
Essentially what?
So that you don't have to bear
legal responsibility for their acts.
So on October 18th the
university mentioned to me in
another warning letter that
if personal pronouns are being used,
the refusal to use the personal pronoun,
that is an expression of the person's
gender identity can constitute
discrimination.
So now you see what's happened is that
I haven't refused to use someone's
gender,
a gender neutral pronouns
I said that I would refuse.
So it's not even the refusal itself
that's producing the letters.
It's my declared intent
to engage in the refusal.
And as far as I was concerned,
what I was essentially doing
was criticizing a piece of
legislation that had not
yet been passed,
but the university's legal department
decided that all that was sufficient for
them to distance themselves from me
and to engage in disciplinary activity.
I would say a a legal
doctrine is something like
a virus and it has a life if
you output,
we think if you,
if you let it go into a living system
that it propagates and it has effects and
the effects are a consequence of the
philosophy that's embedded inside the law.
And if you really want to know about this,
you should read Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn
school leg archipelago because what he
does in that book is tell you how the
hypothetically humane doctrines that were
embedded in radical Marxism at the end
of the 18 hundreds unfolded into Soviet
society and demolished it.
But I want to tell you a little
bit about what the law does.
And this is with regards to its
interpretation from the policy guidelines.
It instantiates social
constructionism into our legal system.
You have to understand what that means.
There's a huge debate about
how human identity is,
is,
um,
uh,
upon what grounds human
identity is predicated.
Now the radical social constructionists
basically say that identity is nothing
but a social construction and not that's
in keeping with their philosophical
doctrines,
partly Marxist and Parsley,
partly postmodern.
But that isn't,
and that was what I was objecting to with
regards to bill [inaudible] because it
insists,
do you understand this?
It makes this legal doctrine
that biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression and sexual orientation
very independently and they don't.
Now the reason they don't
is because 98% of people,
it's 99.7% of people,
by the way,
at least with regards to the most credible
statistics have a gender identity.
This essentially identical with their
biological sex and almost everybody who is
male and female by biological sex
and gender identity dresses that way.
And that's what it gender
expression essentially is.
And then if you stack those three
things on top of each other,
they're basically isomorphic.
You can add sexual orientation to that
and 98% of people are heterosexual.
So the idea that those things very
independently is absolutely preposterous,
but it's written into the law and
that has terrible consequences.
You see,
I don't know,
for example,
now to what degree,
any discussion in universities of the
biological differences between men and
women are legal and you think,
oh,
well that's an exaggeration.
It's like,
well,
the,
I debated Nicholas Matte,
I believe that was his name of professor
at the University of Toronto on TV owes
the agenda.
And he said,
write out for everyone to hear that the
scientific consensus is that there's no
biological differences
between men and women.
And I've received letters from people
who've told me that now the social justice
activist types are complaining about
the fact that the biologists assign
biological sex to animals because it's
only a social construct that we're
projecting onto their being.
And um,
you know,
we just heard that the co,
the chromosomal level
of analysis is complex.
It's not that complex.
What we have is a bi modal distribution
with a tiny number of exceptions in that
by the way,
is not a spectrum.
And one of the things that builds in for
example is the claim that identity is
only subjectively defined.
And that's built right in.
It says that your identity
is whatever you think it is.
Well,
let me tell you,
as a practicing psychologist,
that's absolute rubbish.
Your identity to look when,
when children are two years old,
that's what they think.
They think that their subjective reality
is everything and what you do is you
socialize them between the ages of two
and four to adopt an identity that's part
of a cultural negotiation.
It's like your identity as
part of a cultural negotiation.
It's partly the game you play in.
Partly the game that I play with you and
I have to be a voluntary participant in
that and not only,
not only is it not subjectively defined,
which detaches it entirely,
by the way,
from the underlying biological and
the underlying objective reality,
making any claim you want for
your subjective identity valid.
The other thing it does,
it completely oblivious.
Hates the idea that identity is actually
a Prac pragmatic entity for God's sake.
It's like if you're a lawyer
or a father or mother,
like an identity that
has some solidity to it,
your identity is also a vehicle within
which you traveled through life,
right?
It's a set of tools,
a set of pragmatic tools that you use
to interact with the social and the
natural world.
It's not only your subjective whim.
The idea of gender identity,
which is only defined subjectively in,
in the,
in the relevant law has been studied
intensively by personality psychologist
such as myself.
In fact,
my lab has done some of the,
I wouldn't say the most
fundamental research on it,
but you know,
we're in the boat and
we're in the ballpark.
Here's a little story.
Okay.
So the,
the differences between personality
between men and women are basically what
constitutes gender identity.
And in so far as it's
not merely subjective.
And one of the things that's happened is
that as the Scandinavian countries have
equalize their political
and sociological landscape,
the differences in identity between
men and women have got larger,
not smaller.
Do you understand that?
That's a refutation of the
social constructionist claim.
So what happens is,
is that if you flatten out the
landscape so that there are very few
socioeconomic differences say,
or sociological differences in the
treatment between men and women,
what happens is the biological
difference maximizes,
it maximizes you understand that means
men and women get more different,
not more the same.
And the thing about women in the audience,
bloody hell,
you should think about this because
don't you want to pursue the things that
you're interested in?
And if you pursue the things that you're
interested in because you're interested
in different things than men,
I'm telling you.
And if you look at the interest,
if you look at the interest variation,
this has been established technically.
If you look at the interest variation,
there's almost no overlap
between men and women.
If you sum up the differences in interest,
interest in temperament.
Okay?
Okay.
Professor Peterson.
Let's start with you.
Uh,
so this question says,
you present your issue with bill.
See 16 to be that the infringement of
freedom of expression regarding gender
pronouns is the problem.
Do you hold the same stance with other
discriminatory language and the human
rights code such as being
able to use racist terms,
uh,
with regard to students?
And if you believe that one of these
things is a violation but not the other
one.
Why?
I'm not sure I read that at all that well,
but you get the idea.
Well,
first of all,
I don't think that these
issues are the same.
I don't think they're the same at all.
I mean,
I think being thinking
about the pronoun thing,
you know,
because one of the things that people
put me back on my heels for a while
because the claim was basically,
well it's something like why doesn't
the mean professor just play nice and,
and respect people by
using their pronouns?
And it took me like three weeks to unpack
that because who gets questioned about
Pronoun use?
I don't know why the hell
I use the pronouns I use,
I use them because they're
part of the language I use.
He and she,
because that's what everyone uses.
And so then I had to think about,
well why,
why do we in fact use pronouns?
And we use them in part for the same
reason that we use other categories.
And that's to simplify the
world for functional purposes.
Roughly speaking.
But then I was thinking,
well,
is the use of he and
she a mark of respect?
And the answer to that is,
well no,
it's not a mark of respect.
It can't be a mark of risk.
What you call 4 billion people
can't be a mark of respect.
Right?
It's a,
it's a mark of basic categorization
and so then the claim comes up,
well if someone wants you
to use a particular Pronoun,
then you're disrespecting them.
If you don't,
it's like,
hmm,
okay,
let's think that through a bit.
Well that assumes that when
I'm using he or she for,
for people and you know,
in normal parlance that I'm actually
indicating my respect for them.
And that's not true.
It's like if,
I don't know you,
iCloud is classify you generically and
basically I classify you in terms of how
you present yourself publicly.
I suppose that's your gender expression
and then I nail you with whatever
pronoun seems to fit.
It has nothing to do with respect.
And besides that,
you bloody well don't
get to demand my respect.
Why should you?
You know,
I mean,
it's not like I respect everyone.
That's a foolish thing to do.
You respect people who are respectable.
You know,
you,
you make value distinctions between
people and that doesn't mean you illegally
discriminate against them.
Those aren't the same thing,
but I'm all for value judgements,
so don't tell me that I'm not respecting
people and I don't use their gender
pronouns.
And the other thing is I don't buy
this whole idea that the people who are
putting this legislation forward are
valid representatives of the Trans
community.
That's what they say they are.
We have mechanisms for deciding whether
someone's a valid representative of a
community and that generally
involves democratic voting.
I've received at least 20 letters from
transsexual people who are on my side and
by the way,
zero from others,
believe it or not,
who are perfectly happy with
the idea of gendered pronouns.
It's just they want to be the other one.
Now you can have a discussion about that
and there's lots of things to be said
about it,
but the idea that this community that's
coming out in these demanding these
rights is somehow representative of this
homogenous oppressed minority I think
is rubbish is professor Peterson,
sorry.
As a clinical psychologist refusing
to acknowledge how damaging it could
potentially be to an individual
to disregard their identity.
It's a very difficult question to even
engage with because I don't understand
it's,
I don't understand it.
It makes things so simple that
you can discuss them properly.
All I do in my clinical practice and I
have about 20,000 hours of experience
with clinical in my clinical practice
and I've dealt with all sorts of people,
far more variation in people than the
typical person ever encounters and I think
I've done it at least
reasonably competently.
All my discussions with people in my
clinical practice or about their identity
given the definition of
identity that I brought forth,
how they feel about themselves,
how they conceptualize themselves
cause those are two different things.
How that plays out in their interactions
with other people and what the
functional significance
of that is and I'm,
I'm going to save forthrightly.
Well two things.
One is that I don't believe that any of
my clients have had cause to worry about
my interpretation of their identity.
Because what I do in my practice
is help them what that is.
I'm really,
I'm seriously not interested in imposing
any ideas of identity on to someone.
It's because I don't,
I can't do that.
I don't know what the right vehicle
is for you to travel through life.
What I can help you do is
articulate your concerns.
I can ask you questions where I
see contradictions in yourself.
Articulation.
I can help you make plans for the future.
And I've helped thousands and thousands
and thousands of people by the way,
make plans for the future with
the stuff that I do online.
And so I'm helping people
build a genuine identity.
Um,
well,
and that's what I do.
So that's the answer to that question.
And,
and I think I do it well.
I mean in,
in stuff we've done from a research
perspective with the future authoring
program,
which I offered to people free a week and
a half ago to help them catalyze their
identities.
We've helped 5,000 university students
increase their grade point average 20%
and decrease their dropout by the same.
And the biggest effect
has been with men and,
and on Western ethnic minority students
who've accelerated their performance up
beyond the range of the normal for the,
for the dominant culture,
a pure psychological intervention,
I might say,
a not a sociological intervention.
So I'm perfectly willing to stack my
record on identity formulation up against
anyone.
So and so,
and I should also point out that I
think where I'm most vulnerable in this
entire debate and I expect
this will happen and you know,
there's already been noise about it on
the Ontario Psychological Association
website.
I think that they'll probably
come after my clinical license,
so that,
that'd be my,
that'd be my guess.
So.
So I think we might be straying a
little away from your question now.
So,
uh,
just,
thank you.
Um,
so
I don't know.
We're doing because that's that question
question involved my clinical practice.
I'm not straying a bit that involved my
clinical practice and there was a reason
that the question was
posed so I'm not straying.
Thank you.
Why
do you feel that someone's personal gender
identity and pronouns infringes your
free speech?
Can one not also argue based on your
interpretation that professors can use
racial slurs in their classroom,
um,
and the,
that the inability to do so would
violate their freedom of speech?
Well,
that's pretty much the same question.
I think.
Um,
I think that we're crossing a dangerous
line and the line is the requirement
that's being put upon people by government
agencies with the full force of the
law behind them to decide what language
categories you're going to use.
When I opened this debate,
this forum,
um,
I tried to explain what this is about and
I couldn't explain everything and that
it's about,
because it's about too many things.
But one of the things it's about is it
theology and the distinction between the
left and the right and let's say no.
I truly believe that
these made up pronouns,
of which there are many dozens in fact,
and there's no on them.
Yeah.
With just going to ask,
if you could go back to the point about
the analogy between the racial slur and
the take.
There's any analogy at all,
but that's just what difference here
I'm talking about compelled speech.
There's a difference between saying
that there's something you can't say and
seeing that there are
things that you have to say,
and I regard these made up pronouns,
all of them as the neologisms
of a radical PC authoritarians.
Do you understand that?
And I don't,
I'm not a fan of that sort of person.
And the reason I'm not a fan of that
sort of person is because I've done my
homework.
I've read everything I can get my hands
on in the development of authoritarian
political systems,
and I know the literature
inside out and backwards.
And I am not going to be a mouthpiece
for language that I detest.
Okay.
And that's [inaudible].